and it was a deadly weekend in las vegas
after several pedestrians were killed
nhp
sending out a message to all of the
community about safety as we roll into
saint patrick's day
christian cazares live in studio with
more on these cases
and the nhp game plan that's right brian
well the nhp tells me yesterday was
quote a grim and busy day
in las vegas incidents that could have
all been prevented now take a look here
on your screen this was the scene near
lake mead and lambs
on sunday evening around 9. a pedestrian
was struck by a vehicle as
it was traveling west on lake mead the
victim was taken to the hospital and did
not survive
a few hours before on sunday another
pedestrian was struck
investigators say a white ford pickup
killed the person on sahara and 6th
street
but it was this scene on sunday morning
near prim that has the nevada highway
patrol
very concerned we had a sedan that was
traveling
southbound on i-15 near gene
when one of the occupants or the vehicle
pulled over to the right shoulder and
one of the occupants
exited the vehicle and entered the
northbound travel lane
in order to retrieve some property at
which time
they were struck well if you have an
emergency while driving you should
always pull off to the shoulder as far
as possible
and according to the nhp remain in your
vehicle it's illegal for someone
to be on the highway in the state of
nevada because of how dangerous it can
be
now none of the victims have been
identified nhp also says they will be in
full force for st
patrick's day on wednesday they will be
working with metro police and will be
looking for any impaired drivers
they say the best decision you can make
is to plan ahead and of course
don't drink and drive christian casadas
8 news now